hello everybody hope that are good new
Bitcoin update and I want to start with
the liquidation hit maps in high block
Capital because in one of the time
frames I really can see something
currently happening that we've talked
before okay so let's start with a 7 Days
time frame uh really quickly so if you
notice here uh We've hunt all these
liquidations here at
26,500 and 27,000 price is spiked up now
we are retesting this Z the 27k that's
the mid-range but if you know there is
still qu of liquidity to the upside okay
around
28,500 and of course also to the
downside but you can notice that at
least in the short term the in the lower
time frame the liquidity seems to be to
the upside still okay now if we go into
the 3 months time frame and this is what
I wanted to tell you now we can see
here that the liquidity to the downside
is increasing okay check out these two
uh jell bars at the bottom can you see
them they were not there before and I
was telling you I think it was on Friday
my market theory for the short term and
we were around here I was telling you
that it was not a coincidence that we
didn't hit this liquidations at
24,200 and it was not a coincidence that
we missed it for a couple of hundreds so
what the market making intentions could
be here was to consolidate price and
then Spike price up with a green big
candle so new Traders can open long
position the retail Trader can get
excited and then the liquidation to the
downside can increase you can already
see that that's currently happening so
then when the reverse price back down
and they hit these liquidations finally
then they want to hit more liquidations
that they could have done previously and
you can see that in the chart playing
out now okay so that's in the midterm uh
V Cous I know that all the ATV news are
exciting I'm going to post today a
second video later
and it's going to be a quite different
format it's going to be me in a
PowerPoint just talking about my opinion
of the ETF explaining what it actually
is what the news with gray scale
actually mean and what we can expect in
the new days and months regarding the
ETV news Okay so stay tuned for that
video I think that was going to be quite
interesting um yes basically even if
everything is looking interesting be
careful because the liquidity in the
midterm is still to the downside all
right of course uh this number here 60
billion whatever take it with a pince of
salt already told you that because High
Capital doesn't reduce the liquidations
amounts because they don't know where
the retail Trader is Clos in position so
they can only keep the numbers and
amounts the same or increase them that's
why they have also uh added this new
setting here which scales down the
amounts and here for example it tells
you 2 million okay but we're want to
play with the maximum liquidity because
that's what I'm used to okay for all
this month so uh that's pretty much
everything I want to show you in high
block Capital now let's go to the
Chart so Bitcoin to be honest H moved
since yesterday that was your protion
from yesterday's video and you can see
that I didn't uh really play it out uh
we were expecting the drop the drop
happened but then we were expecting a
reversal and that reversal H never came
okay instead what they are doing is
consolidating price over here you can
see uh that we tested actually the
midrange this white dotted line okay and
now we are consolidating here as the 50
EMA in the Winer time frame is creeping
up and it's catching up with price so um
why is this happening well most likely
because in only 1 hour and a half at
12:30 UTC time we have pce inflation
report and that's going to be quite
important and tomorrow we also have
non-farm payrolls okay so maybe the
market Market is just waiting for some
news announcements and that's why we
consolidate in the past hours all right
so this Total Line If you wonder it
comes from here
okay this is a range when this is a
previous range you have here range highs
range lows and the Total Line is the
mid-range and if you follow that you can
say that the range lows acted as support
you can see that there very clearly and
now the midrange it might be acting as
support okay or that's why it just
happened uh yesterday that we were
dropping and then we stopped at the
mid-range so let's see what happens
today with those
pce inflation report numbers but it's as
simple as this if the results are good
then there's a chance that we might see
you know another test maybe of the 1 or
50 ma or the mid-range and then that L
up to 27,800 is still happening okay
that's is still a chance but if today's
inflation report data is bad then you
have have to be careful because if we
lose these two levels the one or 50 May
and the mid-range and which is the
resistance then we have a long way down
all right also uh if we
check the one the 4 Hour time frame then
this could be the last support okay so
26,800 so if you today you have very bad
inflation data and then you come below
the midrange then you should go towards
this Zone here and if you lose that zone
then of course you're going to retrace
the whole pum from uh the gray scale uh
news Okay so be very careful and keeping
in mind these two levels okay so the
mid-range and then if you lose the
mid-range then you have this Zone over
there all right so uh that's pretty much
everything regarding uh Bitcoin in the 1
hour and 4 hours time frame uh then in
the daily time frame you can see that
our main resistance is also the 50 Ma so
maybe we do some more more you know
ranging in this one here all right
that's a possibility that that's your
new type of uh shortterm range uh but
again today's inflation uh report and
tomorrow's nonfarm payrolls can Catalyst
a move either to the upside or to the
downside and then retrace this whole
pump all right so I always tell you when
we have major news announcements on the
way it's better to stay flat reduce risk
okay because it can go either that way
so be very careful because that's only
going to happen in one and a half from
here and probably around 30 minutes or
so from when I upload the video uh if
I'm quick enough and then if we go to
the quickly time
frame the same story that I was telling
you yesterday okay this candle cruises
on Sunday and in my opinion this candle
is going to be very important because
you can see the 50m in the weekly time
frame here he actually a support and
then you have a l up okay now we closed
the previous weekly candle below the
weekly 50a and this one to be is very
close from it it's like $100 or $200
away so we if we close below it again
and then we start to see the candles
testing the weekly 50 m resistance then
that's saying you okay we want to have
another leg low same as what happened
here but inversely you see what I mean
and the target is going to be uh this
liquidity pool over here uh basically
that's at
22k and of course the 50% of this week
around 20,700 okay so that's what I see
for Bitcoin uh not a clear trade I'm
going to wait myself uh until the
today's inflation report is out before
taking any new trades and see what
happens okay so I'll probably update you
on Twitter in case you want to follow me
there and I'm going to take you to Forex
Factory that's uh one of the website
that I use to to see the the the news
and we're going to go through it okay
and regarding news announcements this
week has been impressively big we've had
loads of you know news announcements we
also had yesterday uh the grayscale uh
case against the SEC okay I'm going to
again I post a video today about the uh
Bitcoin ETF that it's related to that so
in case you have any questions maybe
that video can help you answer them and
also still on Tuesday we got the job
opening survey and this results are
insane okay that's also why the market
uh pumped on Wednesday you also got the
preliminary GDP that was uh look at that
also lower uh bad news for the economy
good news for Jon Powell I think and
also here the I think this is an
automatic let me check this automatic
data processing okay and non farm and
employment change also lower good for
Jon Powell Li Market tring to cool down
it seems but still today you got pce
data very important this is about an an
inflation report you can find some
information here change in the price of
goods and services purchased by
consumers excluding food and energy all
right and then tomorrow which I think is
going to be the the biggest news
announcements is going to be the nonfarm
employment change okay nonfarm payrolls
that's always the first Friday of each
month and this is related to the labor
market so uh stay tuned with this and of
course you also have the employment rate
along this okay so tomorrow is going to
be also a very big day so uh just I
wanted to post this video to keep you
updated about what's currently going on
with Bitcoin and a reminder guys to be
careful with your currently
open with your current open positions
because uh again we're going to have
lots of news and then probably on Friday
we're going to hear some more news about
the Bitcoin ETF uh probably some delays
all right so that's pretty much
everything thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you soon